I'm constantly reminded that you know
I'm responsible for taking another human
being it's like the national
conversation about criminal justice
reform is louder than ever we have a
criminal justice system which is broken
a lot of the talk is focused on reducing
the sentences for nonviolent offenders
but what about violent offenders I sat
down this chalk assange Gore who spent
19 years in prison for second-degree
murder to ask him about it all basically
I kind of seduced into the crack trade
the older more seasoned street hustlers
got stopped multiple times and I didn't
know at the time that I was suffering
from post-traumatic stress disorder I
began to carry a gun everyday got into a
conflict with a group of guys who kinda
bastard drugs at a moment when I felt
there was a potential threats I turned
and fired four fatal shots and for that
crime I was sentenced to 17 to 40 years
in prison you ended up serving 19 yeah
seven that was in solitary confinement
and when I got out I literally had spent
half more likely I have no life oh how
should we begin to talk about violent
offenders 90% of people incarcerated it
regardless to whether you're fighting
enough right over returned to society
and if we are under the illusion that
only now by defenders are coming back to
society then it doesn't allow us to
really engage people in honest way our
system is set up to break and destroy
it's not it's not meant to rehab or
transform or redeem you cannot punish
people
indeterminately and then wake up one day
and say okay it's time for you to go
home and be a civilized citizen Hillary
Clinton in 1996 where she called young
black kids that were in similar
circumstances that you were super
predators when you think about somebody
identifying inner city as a super
predator it just shows how disconnected
they are from everyday realities of
cities like Detroit
unfortunately you know children get shot
everyday in the inner city and they
never get treatment if my shooting would
have taken place in the suburbs there
would have been a very different
response in the reactions in the Vienna
shot there are gonna be people who watch
this interview and think this this man
is responsible for taking the life of
another human being why should I feel
any sort of empathy or compassion for
him I'm not really concerned whether if
somebody feels empathy or compassion for
me how do we really help those who are
coming back home how do we ensure that
our tax dollars are being spent in a way
that creates a healthier positive more
progressive society